bonsoir gilbert abergel merci de
répondre à nos questions l'état reprend
donc la main puisque ce sont le premier
ministre et les ministères concernés 1
qui reprennent les missions
d'observateurs de la laïcité
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
effet d'annoncé ou véritable avancée non
reçues ce n'est pas je ne pense pas tous
d'une seule canne qualifié d' annonce
puisqu'en fait de ce dispositif
interministériel vient couronner tout
arsenal législatif qui va être
définitivement voté donc le 22 juillet
cette loi dite séparatisme
cette loi comporte un certain nombre de
dispositions que nous réclamions nous
associations aux laïcs depuis de
nombreuses années nous souhaitions que
ce sont ces lois ne restent pas quand at
war est en fait le dispositif mis en
place à travers ce comité
interministériel nous garantit que on va
passer du discours aux concret donc nous
attendons beaucoup effectivement de
cette de cette structure
nous espérons qu'elle ne générera pas
les déceptions qui ont été yeux produite
par l'observatoire de laïcité
aujourd'hui l'esa et nous suivrons très
très régulièrement ses travaux il est
prévu que qu'un rapport annuel soit
délivré il est prévu qu'un certain
nombre effectivement de décisions soient
contrôlés mise en oeuvre voilà c'est
c'est le carburant qui fonctionne et ce
dispositif se loi séparatisme justement
le projet de loi séparatisme qui sera
définitivement voté la semaine prochaine
le projet de loi comportant les
principes de la république puisqu'il a
été il a été renommé
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque du coup
vous dites que c'est un panel tout un
ensemble 1
qui arrive donc ça veut dire que c'est
une refondation nécessaire c'est ça ou
bien c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
reculades vis-à-vis de certains
politiques notamment du côté de la
droite radicale
non non je pense que c'est un signe
majeur de la fin de cette période de
déni qui a caractérisé notre classe
politique depuis des années devant c'est
ce phénomène qui est la montée de
l'islam radical
donc on en a pris conscience il ya eu le
discours des mureaux il a eu discours de
mulhouse et il y à un dispositif qui
aujourd'hui va nous permettre d'agir
toutes les situations que nous avons
dénoncé depuis des années vont pouvoir
avoir des réponses législatives
les préfets vont être dotés de pouvoirs
les juridictions françaises ne seront
pas chapeautée par une quelconque que
comines que fin juridiction extra x
extra républicain extra nationale bref
on aura les moyens de faire donc c'est
un véritable pour nous c'est un
véritable pas en avant alors que des
rations du cfcm n'ont pas tous deux
signé la charte de la république
non elles ne l'ont pas tous signé c'est
un signe quand même c'est un signe ça
veut dire qu'il ya une crise de la
laïcité en france il n'y a pas de crise
les sites en france il y à une laïcité
qui doit être défendu ardemment qui doit
être clarifiée
nous avons organisé récemment des des
conférences pour remettre en place les
véritables concept la laïcité c'est très
simple liberté absolue de conscience
c'est la loi de la république au dessus
de toutes les lois particulières au
dessus des lois communautaires c'est la
possibilité pour la fois d'être au
dessus de la loi c'est finalement c'est
simple
le problème c'est que devant les
événements que nous avons vécu et pour
certains d'entre eux très dramatique
notre notre classe politique de
fonctionnaires nos enseignants étaient
dépourvues de réponse et le le le volet
qui concerne la formation donc de cette
fonction publique à la fois hospitalière
mais aussi territoriale est un volet
important rigaux je crois justement la
formation la dent dans les écoles dans
les hô pital façon généralisée
obligatoires
quel effet concrètement selon vous
ça va avoir et comment rendre tout ça
applicable sur le terrain alors d'abord
d'abord on sait très bien que la
formation de produits rap ne produira
pas cesser immédiatement
on a pris beaucoup de retard cette
formation correspond à une véritable
demande de la part de ces de ses
fonctionnaires de terrain qui nous
disaient non sait pas comment faire
combien d'enseignants qui ont été
désarmés devant un certain nombre de
manifestations d'enfants et
d'adolescents de revendication de
protestation de leurs contenus de
contenu de leurs cours
donc effectivement c'est cette formation
est importante
seul le travail peut être va être très
difficile à faire
encore une fois parce que nous avons
attendu longtemps beaucoup reste à faire
comment il pourrait faire ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire c'est un travail c'est
des mentalités à changer ça
bien sûr ce sont des mentalités à
changer parce qu'en fait on s'attache
aujourd'hui à ceux qui sont en prise
directe avec le public un la fonction
publique territoriale la fonction
hospitalière
mais vous avez tout une toute une série
de citoyens qui sont des animateurs dur
de réseaux associatifs et qui eux sont
parfois perdus
je vous donne un exemple il y a dans une
une ligue 2 de football en région des
demandes qui sautille émane de la part
de formateur au foot donc école de
formation des demandes qui émanent de
leur part qu'ils disent mais nos gamins
veulent le des repas halal la loi le
comité des sages a répondu non il n'y a
pas de repas halal dans les internats et
c'est ces formateurs qui disent oui mais
si on leur donne pas de repas halal on
va perdre on va perdre des compétences
sportives
voyez que la conscience de ce que c'est
que la laïcité n'est pas n'est pas bien
partagée et les gens ne savent pas où
elle en est il consomme tout la
coexistence des religions avec la
laïcité l'a décidé c'est très simple
c'est pas de communautarisme c'est un
individu est un citoyen avant d'être un
membre d'une communauté la laïcité donc
un des fondements de notre république
avec
cette nouvelle instance est-ce que
la laïcité perd son indépendance
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif qui maintenons
donc chapeauté directement dans d'en
haut par rapport à ça qu'elle est votre
votre analyse bien fait ou effets
pervers
nono je pense que l'exécutif est dans sa
mission c'est à korem à lui de veiller
au respect des valeurs républicaines et
puis le fait que ce soit effectivement
interministériel que les principaux
ministères concernés prennent la parole
et les moyens d'agir me paraît tout à
fait important dans cet important que
l'exécutif prenne ses responsabilités
merci gilbert abergel d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
le président du comité laïcité
république